à l'entrée de la ville c'est un pont qui
a marqué les premiers jours de la guerre
aujourd'hui il est en pleine
reconstruction la vieille partie sera
toutefois conservée pour en faire un
mémorial
car en mars ce dernier sépare là que des
centaines de personnes fuyant l'avancée
des troupes russes traversaient à pied
pour tenter de se mettre à l'abri
bien des habitants sont maintenant
revenus
il y a des chantiers de construction un
peu partout
on bouche les trous fait par les éclats
d'obus on veut effacer les traces de
tout ce que la ville a subi
cela prendra du temps la Maison de la
Culture un bâtiment classé des années 50
et toujours dans le même état cette
responsable de la ville qui a travaillé
pendant des années estime qu'il faut
regarder en avant
on a déjà payé un prix tellement élevé
en vie humaine dit-elle en confort en
bien on ne peut pas reculer maintenant
on peut juste avancer
la guerre cependant n'est jamais loin
ici des résidents du quartier se sont
rassemblés dans la cour pour saluer une
dernière fois un de leurs voisins du
micro Samantha avait 34 ans il était
volontaire dans l'armée ukrainienne il
est mort la semaine dernière aux abords
de barmouth dans cette bataille
particulièrement meurtrière
sa mère est inconsolable
[Musique]
que je
ils sont l'avenir de notre pays nous dit
cette femme dont le fils est aussi dans
l'armée mais nous croyons à la victoire
quelques prières encore et le temps est
venu de partir un petit cortège se forme
pour prendre le chemin du cimetière
l'offensive russe a bien sûr commencé
ses ravages bien plus tôt à erpin une
partie de la ville a été complètement
détruite dans les violents combats au
tout début de l'invasion l'occupation
qui a suivi a été terrible des centaines
de corps ont été découverts à erpin
comme dans la ville voisine de boucha
certains avaient été torturés c'est à la
bibliothèque que nous rencontrons Lina
ou kraainnitz sa maison n'existe plus
son fils aîné qui était membre de la
défense territoriale a fait sauter un
camion citerne russe avant d'être blessé
selon des témoins un soldat tchétchène
ensuite achevé à bout
portant-ils venus sur notre terre nous
avions une vie paisible prospère et eux
sont venus fusillés et des civils Lina
redoute maintenant une nouvelle
offensive des Russes mais depuis le
temps elle a aussi appris à vivre avec
cette inquiétude permanente
nous n'avons pas le choix c'est eux ou
c'est nous dit-elle soit on résiste soit
il nous anéantissent
ou cimetière
on retrouve les proches du soldat tué à
barmouth quelques prières encore puis
Nitro sera enterré avec d'autres
militaires tombés dans les derniers
jours
dans un pays libre nous dit sa femme il
est allé se battre pour sa famille pour
ses amis pour le drapeau ukrainien la
sœur de nitro est aussi anéantie ce 12h
je n'ai pas les mots pour dire notre
peine dit-elle tout ce que j'espère
c'est que mon frère soit le dernier à
mourir dans cette maudite guerre
une guerre qui se poursuit pourtant et
qui risque d'être plus brutal encore ici
Céline Galipeau Radio-Canada irpin